do what I love choose something that you
love to do I really love what I'm doing
this is what I want to do
hello believe nation today we're gonna
talk about how to love what you do and
as always guys as you're watching the
videos if you see something that really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired and
if you write it down it's much more
likely to stick with yourself as well
[Music]
I'm very spiritual person and I follow
my spirit and I do what my spirit tells
me to do you know and I don't have a set
like oh I want to play this type of
character and I won't play that type of
character I'm receptive to anything you
know and when the right thing comes
along if it's serious that was funny if
it's silly if it's low but see I'm but
it put it this way I do I just do
whatever makes me I get the most
gratification from as an artist you know
I do music albums and nobody buys my
records I do them because I love making
music you know and that's the same way
I'm about movies I don't make movies
because I'm going to thinking let me do
this because then people will come or
how much will the movie make and trying
to make the audience do that I do what
feels right for me what were you like as
a child I I was a combination of
reclusive and obsessed with what I
wanted to do when I was 2 I want I was
sitting in front of the TV drawing Fred
Flintstone's and woody woodpecker's and
at age 7 I'm running around like a crazy
person doing voices but at the same time
I would try to make animated films and
try to figure out exactly how that
artform worked when did you do your
first cartoon how old were you and what
was it I was in seventh grade it was
called space pirates it was terrible Oh
No
about trying to make what I think people
will like you know it I think because it
doesn't sound like one full album from
top to bottom people disregard it
because it's all over the place people
think it's messy or chaotic but I think
it's beautiful chaos and it's perfect
then it's my favorite album to date
regardless of what anyone says and I can
understand why people don't like it it's
different and sometimes different
doesn't equal good to some people but I
love it and you know that's great that's
all that matters in me if you if you
make something you 100% love and
everyone loves it that's a win-win
that's great you have something that you
really love that everyone makes it at
least you love it and you just move on I
woke up every morning excited I was
completely jacked I've never been more
excited to go to work every day as I was
on this project at the end of the day
I've never been more drained in my life
but somehow someway I found the energy
every morning to get up and just go for
it and the further we got into it the
more Wayne was just like okay do what
you want to do do what you want to do
and I never had that kind of freedom
before you know I have tons of things
I'd like to do
and life is short unfortunately but I
hope it will be long enough for me to do
to do some of these I have known a few
writers who have retired
I cannot imagine ever retiring I did
writing and being a writer is too much
part of my identity and too much part of
what I am I don't know what I would do
with all that time if I did stop writing
you know play video games or something
like that watch a lot more television
that it seems unlikely to me I've always
told stories whether I could make my
living from it or even when I was a
little kid just making up stories for
the other kids in the neighborhood and I
think I'm gonna continue to do that
until the end why not when I talk to
three first-time filmmakers or
first-time filmmakers I always tell them
look making movies is eating a sandwich
and the only thing that gets a little
better is as the years go by you get a
little more breadth but there's always
there but isn't it that true of life
also I think it is I mean I I use
another metaphor for life but for film I
tell you that one fits and but in the
end somehow you find the joy
well you and you end up convincing
yourself that it's peanut butter
I want to believe it is though always
the best I did that I tell you without a
doubt we we may say this with is the
greatest being an artist in whatever
discipline dance painting theater
whatever you want is the greatest work
on earth I mean it's truly this hard
thing in that in this way or that way
but so is every job so is every job I
when I was younger I worked with my
father on real estate for about five
years I was
worst car salesman in the history of
Carl sighs McCallister's lets you buy
was Fischer too honest
yeah people would come and say what
about designing you know Glengarry Glen
Ross I would not get the knife set I
would I would be I would be Shelly live
in I would be out out
it was terrible my father said you do
terrible but I wonder the other vendors
whenever whenever I went out the other
salesmen whenever I went out to a client
they actually laughed behind my back
actually physically were laughing behind
my back and I was the worst but in real
estate I was good I was good or is it
and my father used to say you have to do
this to show that you can have an honest
living do an honest living
and what I did is work on real estate in
the mornings and I did monsters in the
afternoon but I know that when you have
a real job
I painted highways one summer in which
the cancers I mean a real job has equal
heartbreaking some like that in politics
well I mean this is for I think it's one
of the things that people really
misunderstand as is glorious it is to be
able to do the things you're passionate
about and to be an artist it's still a
job it is not diligent work yeah yeah it
is it is but but God god bless anyone
that can do this is beautiful and you
have to truly be grateful and the only
way to remain objective about how
grateful you need to be is present your
present to your past self when you're 20
years old and if you go and talk to
yourself at 20 years old and said would
you like to be doing this movie with
this button what do you think your
response at age 20 would be absolutely
yes I knew I wanted to be in the skin
industry I loved skating too much I
wanted I wanted to be in it I didn't
know if I would make a living as a
professional but I was gonna be I was
devoted to skateboarding so i refinanced
my house and took all the money and
started a skateboard company which seems
like the stupidest thing in the world to
do when skating is dying but it was
exactly what what I wanted to do I
wanted to be a company owner and be
behind the scenes I
quickly sponsor and and started and for
about three years struggled very very
hard with my partner and I we had pulled
our minds together he was a ex pro
skater as well and we just we just did
birdhouse and did whatever we could to
get by and all the team was staying on
my couch and literally like want
changing diapers I'm like driving guys
to these spots that they're gonna get
arrested at because there's no skate
park so they're gonna go ride
schoolyards and it was such a strange
existence but but I loved it because it
was skateboarding and is exactly what I
wanted to do and so we really hunkered
down you know like I was I was living on
Taco Bell and peanut butter and jelly
and Top Ramen mmm probably three years
for sure but I didn't care because it
was like I still got to do what I love
that's the thing is that people think
was a struggle it's like well no because
you know I loved it too much I still got
to go skate and I had time to skate I
didn't have to go sit behind a computer
for eight hours and then hope I get time
to skate Mark Twain once said the two
most important days of your life or the
day you were born and the day you find
out why the first of those has already
happened to you because you're sitting
right here okay the second the day that
you find out why you're born may have
already happened to many of you and to
the others not yet but you will know
when it happens it will be connected to
something that you truly love I've
always said to my five sons choose
something that you love to do and you'll
never work a day in your life
I really love what I'm doing not just so
much for people like all find your
passion and go do it a lot of people
claim something is something they really
like but I enjoy marketing so much in
creating companies for marketers that I
work my butt off and it doesn't seem
like work right I can work 70 80 hour
weeks consistently and not have to worry
about it never stresses me out and never
feel
I should take a vacation any of that I
really do enjoy working my workaholic
this is my life this is also me living
you tune in
and what you should walk away from what
I would want you most to walk away with
is the idea of yo what can I do
what am I doing with my life am i living
it or am I just you know going to some
humdrum job that I don't really want to
be at doing some minuscule tasks
getting paid to be a mindless drone you
know am i out there living life on my
terms the way I want to live it doing
the things that I want to do making
almost think about it as hard as this is
as hard as this is this is what I want
to do
this is what I want to do
you know and some people can make fun of
it they can crack jokes they can sit
back and analyze and you know criticize
and make all the fun they want
but I'm living my life
I'm doing it
what are you thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know which of the clips had the biggest
impact on you and why which message
resonated with you the most leave it
down in the comments below and I'm gonna
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to Steph reveron
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and taking that
picture and posting it I really really
really appreciate your support so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you soon